I wanted to continue my investigation, so I decided
to add another term. This time I used the
word election. And here's what was interesting, I noticed
these peaks spaced evenly out over time. And then I
realized that these peaks made a lot of sense
because the US Presidential election occurs every four years
in November. If I hover right over the graph,
I can see these peaks in November. Finally, I wanted
to see if there was a word that appeared more than
any of these other words in the last few years. So,
I typed in the word Facebook. This created a drastic change
in the vertical scale in the graph. And I noticed Facebook
didn't even come out on the scene until around 2007. I
think it's pretty cool that a word such as Facebook draws
words like chicken, music and movies. Facebook is certainly the giant
when it comes to this graph. This is one small example of
how data is everywhere around us and it's waiting
to be explored. Let's have you get your hands
dirty, by performing your own trend analysis. Search for
celebrities, music, movies, or anything else that you find
interesting. You can use the time series graph that
I used, or something else on the site. Once
you've got your exploration, share it on the forums,
and comment on any posts that you find interesting.